what keeps me up late at night in the
sense of worry I guess its innovation
it's funny to be worried about it
because it's a fair point that wow look
at the innovation we've seen over the
past not just 30 years but over the past
two years but I also see ways in which
the kind of truly revolutionary
applications like the World Wide Web
that have come about kind of
unsuspecting to the incumbents whether
government incumbents are corporate
income Bin's like big telcos or
something those get harder and harder to
pull off as the devices and services
people use are more controllable by a
handful of vendors it's hard to try to
be a canary in the coalmine here because
right now we're enjoying such innovation
but at the same time we are truly in the
midst of a sea change in how
controllable the technology we use day
by day is and it is getting more and
more controllable by a distinct group of
entities who may have our best interests
in mind at least as consumers right now
but they can change their minds or be
regulated forced to change their minds
later so that keeps me up at night and
when I think of being kept up at night
in a positive sense I actually think
about the possibilities behind so-called
ad-hoc mesh networking the ability for
these ubiquitous computers little
processors we have everywhere whether a
birthday card or a handheld phone to
talk to each other and like a bucket
brigade get bits moving from one place
to another with no internet service
provider having to be formally involved
in many of the steps the kinks haven't
been worked out on that yet but if we
had such a thing and could deploy such a
thing because there are enough to be
programmable devices in our hands that
you buy it to be a word processor on one
day one but on day five suddenly it's
got mesh networking that means that if
Hurricane Katrina hits and takes out
most networks and power or if the
Chinese government
is to clamp down and try to cut off the
internet neither gets much in the way
because as long as you are near other
people bits are shuffling from one
person to the next like Hands Across
America out to drop points and exchange
points so that's one of the most
interesting pieces of basic research
that I think is worth keeping an eye on
that could transform this constant
battle between cat and mouse and how
regulable the internet can be